The development of the Systematized Nomenclature of Medicine, or SNOMED,
traces its roots to a project began in the 1960s
by Dr. Arnold Pratt at the National Institutes of Health,
or NIH, to use natural language processing to
machine code pathologist free-text dictated notes.
Thus, from the outset,
it was an ontology representing relationships among its concepts.
Today, it extends to all of medicine and is maintained by
the International Health Terminology Standards Development Organization (IHTSDO).
SNOMED is huge and complex.
The most recent US version of it,
SNOMED CT subset for clinical medicine,
still has over 311,000 concepts with over 1.3 million relationships among them.
Given its scope, you may find references to SNOMED CT in many types of FHIR resources.
In this course, we'll focus only on SNOMED CT. Concepts are
the basic component of SNOMED CT and have
a unique nine-digit SNOMED CT identifier or SCTID.
Each SNOMED CT concept also has a unique human-readable Fully Specified Name or FSN.
Here, I have used
the official IHTSDO SNOMED CT browser to search for the term hypertension.
I got 705 matches and selected one of
several that has a Fully Specified Name of hypertensive disorder,
systemic arterial, which I'll just call hypertension in what follows.
Its SCTID is 38341003.
Here, you see the 14 synonyms for hypertension.
This list could be quite useful in processing text notes or problems from
a structured list and might contain one or more of these alternative terms.
You can also see the hierarchical nature of SNOMED CT.
Hypertension is a child of disorders of cardiovascular system that is
a child of disorder of body system and so on all the way to the top of the hierarchy.
Any intermediate level of this hierarchy could
be useful in grouping patients for analysis.
Hypertension, in turn, has 23 sub-disorders called children.
These can also be useful for grouping patients for analysis.
The browser also provides a diagrammatic hierarchical view.
A careful look at this shows how SNOMED explicitly
reveals important computable clinical relationships.
Absent this, how might a computer know that
hypertension is associated with an increased blood pressure?
Here's a second, more interesting,
example for prolapse of the mitral valve due to rheumatic disease.
A physician would know that
the root cause was a streptococcal infection that triggered the body
to attack the heart valve because of the similarity of some of
its surface proteins to those of the bacteria.
How would a computer know this?
SNOMED makes it explicit.
Finally, the references view provides a great deal of
potentially useful information in the form of
relationships between the current concept and others.
You can see that they are in five groups,
we will discuss only the first two but I would suggest you explore the others.
Associated findings are clinical findings that might
occur with hypertension such as a family history of the disease.
Associated with, are clinical findings that hypertension patients may have.
I've expanded that view here to show, for example,
that they might have one or more of a number of kidney diseases
that can cause or be caused by high hypertension.
Again, this is potentially very useful information for analysis of clinical data.
SNOMED is quite a bit more complex than I've presented here in this brief overview.
Nevertheless, I hope I've been able to convince you that it can be a very valuable tool.